this is a production of Cornell
University good afternoon everyone
Thanks for Dr L thanks to Dr Lou for
introducing me it was nice introduction
uh he doesn't know me much but uh he
introduced very well yeah so lots are
moving from University of sental Florida
to here so um today's my a exam present
a I will be talking about evaluation and
development of ecosystem model um to
understand belog carbon and hydrological
process I will mostly talk about three
components model below ground carbon and
hydrological process in fact this
hydrological process will how this
hydrological process will influence
carbon cycle I will mostly talk about
that
thing so why soil is important soil
stores a largest amount of carbon
compared to vegetation and atmospheric
carbon combined so even a small change
in soil can uh Small Change in solar
organic carbon can lead to significant
effect in the climate how this small
change could
be so 1% change in Sol organic carbon
could be equivalent to 3.4 million times
an adult elephant so this is not small
uh just imagine a state full of 3.4
million
elephants so how uh then as we all know
carbon dioxide concentration is
increasing and climate is warming how
this climate change will influence all
organic carbon we use process based
model and these process there are
several process based model we use to
predict soil organic carbon estimate uh
in the
soil but uh this study that compared 11
Earth System model and it shows there is
very high uncertainty in ating Sol oric
carbon where yeah this is 11 System
model where uh the y axis represent
model carbon and x-axis represent
observed we can see the fitting is not
very
good so where these uncertainties are
coming from uh there could be three
sources of uncertainty first structure
second parameterization and third
external forcing and I am fortunate
enough to implement all these three uh
uncertainties to reduce uh to reduce
uncertainty into my research uh in my
thesis which I will discuss one by one
how I will use this uh steps to reduce
the
uncertainty so in my thesis uh I'm going
to you I'm going to study two major
processes in the below ground those are
microbial processes and the second one
is hydrological
hydraulic redistribution so why
microbial
models why microbial processes microbial
as we all know for anything to decompose
we need microbes microbes are the major
and key role to decompose anything and
recently a paper published by f um
microbial carbon use efficiency promotes
global so carbon stock that was the
title in nature and it says why carbon
microbes they are important in
stabilizing um carbon in the soil so I
Reed 71 microbial models because they
are in the
recent where yeah in the recent public
published paper we can see uh the number
of microbial models is developing get
developed every um yeah recently so very
high development of microbial models as
we can see in the recent past years huge
development big development um
so uh in this study I reviewed 71
microbial models to to compare why there
are 71 different microbial models so
what are the differences between all
these
models uh so what is first of all what
is microbial model uh it is a so biog
geochemical model that simulates uh at
least one microbial biomass
pool and it was not very straightforward
to Define microbial model U because
microbial biomass can be represented as
decomposer of Sol organic carbon here we
can see CB means microbial biomass they
take part in the decomposition of so
organic carbon um but microbes in some
models they can also be act as a
substrate pool where we can have
microbial biomass but they are not
taking part in the decomposition of all
organic
carbon so uh to understand the
differences among all the microbial
models I set up some objectives uh these
are the objectives to identify and
characterize major microbial processes
incorporated into microbial models to
elucidate the environmental factors
influencing microbial process and to
identify challenges and uh conclude it
with some
recommendation after reviewing 71 models
I found uh there are four major
microbial processes that are commonly
incorporated into microbial models those
are microbial mediated
decomposition mineral interaction
microbial necromass Recycling and active
and dorment microbial
Dynamics here I will discuss uh yeah
this enzymatic pathway means these
models they have extra pool of enzyme
which are released by microbes and rest
of 30 models they have only microbial
biomass pool in the model where they
don't explicitly represent enzyme
but microbial biomass itself it is
decomposing solic
carbon so I will discuss one by one
these
processes
so so first process microbial mediated
decomposition there are several uh
method there are several uh mathematical
equations that have been used to
represent microbial mediated
decomposition first one um it is zero
order microbial model here again the
microbial biomass we can see microbial
biomass is present but it is not taking
part in the decomposition reaction so uh
this decomposition equation it is
independent of micrell biomass so I ter
this equation as a zero order micrel
model in general it is linear equation
but it is independent of micrel model
micrel biomass that's why I named it as
zero order microbal
model then second
mechanism here decomposer microbial
biomass the decomposition of so organic
matter uh is decomposed by microbial
biomass pool and it is directly U
related to microbial biomass pool uh
that I termed as first order microbial
biom microbial model then third forward
micus M this is nonlinear equation where
decomposition decomposition of Sol
organic carbon it depends on both
microbial biomass as well as Sol oranic
carbon content that's why it is
nonlinear equation and here micr
biomass uh yeah it does take part in
decomposition
reaction uh and here in forward mless M
they assume the major assumption is
decomposition saturates as we increase
the Sol organic carbon
content then later on another mechanism
was developed that is reverse meus main
here again same um decomposition depends
on microbial biomass po as well as
substrate but uh the decomposition
saturates with the increase in microbal
biomass or enzyme
content so combining all together
overall among 71 micrel models I found
most of the models they use forward mess
mainten and followed by reverse mless
Main and overall uh the micrell models
they have nonlinear representation of
decomposition not all Sol carbon
decomposed uh lead to Sol carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere some are stabilized in
the soil how these are represented in
microbial models they are represented by
mineral interaction where uh the
decomposition uh microbes they decompose
so organic carbon and they get attached
to the clay
component so clay component they protect
so organic carbon from microbes so that
microbes are not accessible to so
organic carbon and those organic carbon
they are stabilize in the environment in
the soil as compared to Conventional
model conventional model is U the model
which does not explicitly represent
microbial biomass so here we don't have
any biomass pool so the conventional
model they
assume uh decomposition of any Sol
organic carbon it is totally depends on
chemical property not on the microbial
or Sol or Minal component so if any
carbon is leile they will decompose
easily and if they are Rec consistent
not easy to decompose chemically
reconsent then they will not be able to
decompose what will have uh what is the
fate of microbal biomass in the
microbial model where does the microbial
necromass go so microbial necromass is
the dead microbial um carbon and also
extracellular enzyme which are been
released by microbes so these uh
component microbial biomass uh product
they have different chemical property
than the plant liter so some of the
microbial models they assume that
because their chemical properties
different microbial necromass proper
chemical properties different then uh so
we should we should show a different at
a separate pool rather than uh the death
microbial biomass is going in the plant
liter uh because the CN ratio of
microbial biomass is different than
plant liter so microbial models they as
some of the microbial models they assume
microbial necromass uh uh should be
represented in a separate pool uh that
follows different decomposition
pattern and the fourth and the last uh
process that is active and dorment State
uh
and uh soils they are always under
unfavorable envirment condition so
microbes they are not always actively
decomposing Sol organic carbon some part
of the microbes they are dorant in
dorment state some are dead so while
representing all microbial biomass as
active some mic we should represent some
of the uh yeah some part of the ACT
total microbial biomass as dorant
because these dorant microbes they are
not actively decomposing Sol organic
carbon if we include also if we also
include dment microbial biomass in total
microbial biomass then we may be
overestimating the effect of microbes so
representing dorment um we reduce the
amount of microbes that are decomposing
Sol oranic
carbon then all these processes uh they
are not acting at same same state in all
environmental situation so
uh at different envirment condition they
are acting differently uh because of
temperature moisture pH redox potential
there are so many environmental
variables that are causing U different
uh rate of these uh
processes so I analyzed and I found most
of mostly in most all of the microbial
models soil
temperature moisture and pH were very
commonly used to represent the influence
of environment on these processes and
soil temperature they were represented
by qan function arous function
generalized poson and arang these are
the functions through which temperature
effect was incorporated into the model
then soil moisture uh they also play
very important role in um the influence
the oxygen because if we have saturated
soil uh there will be less oxygen that
is available to microbes and microbes
will not be activ decomposing so organic
carbon then soil PH they affect uh they
affect mineral surface if there is high
pH mineral surface will not absorb Sol
organic carbon actively there will be
less absorption of Sol organic carbon on
the mineral
surface like all models are not perfect
uh there are still some challenges and
um that are posed by microbial models
these are
some U these microb models they assume
that decomposition of solar in carbon
they are rate limited by the amount of
micr present in the soil however several
studies also
found that abiotic factor such as uh
mineral surface they have more influence
on the stabilization of Sol organic
carbon or decomposition of Sol organic
carbon so we need more experimental
evidence to prove uh microbes they play
uh a limiting agent for the
decomposition of uh organic carbon then
more observational data are needed to
constrain microbial model parameters as
we saw there are four process these four
processes they are they have very
complex mathematical equations and we
have limited U observational data so to
constraint all these parameters we have
very limited data so we need more data
to represent all these processes and
incorporation of more process leads to
uh complexity of a model again to uh it
leads difficulty in constraining
parameters so uh this is conclusion of
summary from my first part uh four major
microbal processes and then uh same um
microbial processes are represented by
different and several mathematical
equations that represent uh uncertainty
in
translating uh these processes into
mathematical form and then data d uh
development and parameterization are
highly recommended to improve prediction
of any
model then uh second part of my study uh
a second key component for belr carbon
um that is hydraulic redistribution uh
understanding hydraulic redistribution
and its impact on water and carbon
dioxide in
drylands Dr Dryland they occupy 40% of
terrestrial surface but they are poorly
represented in Earth System model uh
because we don't know much how Dryland
they function and very limited knowledge
uh we need to improve our understanding
how dry land ecosystem
functions and dry land ecosystem they
are mostly limited by uh water
availability in the
soil so to improve Dr drland ecosystem
representation this uh hydraulic
redistribution is very important so what
is hydraulic
redistribution the definition is
movement of water uh from um weight to
dry region of the soil using uh plant
roots plant roots they move water from
wet regon to dry
regon I can explain it in some uh this
image uh this first image they represent
data time and during daytime uh
transpiration demand is very high transp
transpiration water demand is very high
that leads to very
low five
minutes okay
thanks yeah sorry
yeah yeah so uh yeah during daytime uh
transpiration of water demand is very
high that leads to very significant
water potential gradient from ground to
Leaf level and during daytime water is
moving from ground ground to leave but
during night time transp water demand is
less and in the dry and in the dry soil
air it becomes very dominant um the
water potential become very negative
very less as compared to we regon so
plant what plant roots do they take
water from the wet region and they
translocate it to drer region um yeah
the movement of water from W to dry but
in the rainy season as we know uh
because of rain water will be uh we have
much water in the surface layer and
water uh the surface layer will become
much wter than the Deep soil layer in
the dry land and during nighttime plant
roots they take water from the surface
and they take it to down to the U dryer
regon so this is the understanding of
hydraulic
redistribution there are several uh
experimental and modeling Studies have
been conducted uh to understand how uh
to understand the mechanism Hy hydraulic
redistribution but most of these studies
they uh they use empirical study or even
if they have used model they use one
dimension hydraulic model not carbon not
carbon coupled model so in this study I
will uh I will focus on only mainly in
carbon
side how hydraulic redistribution will
influence carbon cycle
so is there any proof for hydraulic
redistribution so this is data I have um
this is sap flow from two U lateral
roots of a juniper tree here uh this
line horizontal line at zero it means uh
the curve below zero it means water is
moving from root to soil and curve uh
above Das line it means water is moving
from soil to root and this reason it
occurs at night time so during nighttime
roots are translocate transferring water
from root to
soil so my scientific question uh is
when where and how much uh this
hydraulic redistribution play
significant role in
regulating uh water and mainly uh carbon
Dynamics to address these scientific
question I will uh I have said these
object objectives first I will develop
uh ecosystem model that couples water
and carbon cycle uh and I will calibrate
it using onsite uh data available and
then I will analyze the sensitivity of
hydraulic redistribution model uh to uh
water and carbon Dynamics in response to
different environmental
scenario uh I will create different
environmental scenario um then I have to
understand how different environmental
scenario will affect water and carbon
cycle then at the end I will quantify
and characterize seasonal Dynamics when
in what season what what timing uh this
hydraulic redistribution uh will have
significant
effect so this is my experimental site
in New Mexico uh seata if
uh then I will use data like forcing
variables soil temperature precipitation
solar radiation U soil water potential
uh soil water content and sa Flux Of
lateral
Roots uh this is the model I will be
using for hydraulic redistribution it
has
um canopy
photosynthesis plant growth transfer of
liter from plant to soil and soil Water
Dynamics where I will be working on this
part I have to I will modify this soil
Water Dynamics by adding hydraulic
redistribution so in the uh in the uh
original model the Water Dynamics they
are represented by unsaturated water
flow uh evap evapor uh evaporation and
transp ation and I will be adding this
extra hydraulic redistribution movement
of water from U wet region to dry region
through
rules so this is simplified uh version
of hydraulic redistribution model where
uh the first part CRT it is maximum
radial soil root conductance means whole
root uh plant root how much water they
they are able to translocate or move
then uh metric potential difference it
governs the direction of where the water
will be
moving uh if uh J is greater than I it
means water will move from layer J to
I then CI and CJ it is uh the ability of
plants to ro uh to move water as
compared to how much uh it can uh yeah
it can move um yeah then fraction of
active root in layer I how much root
layer how much roots are active in the
soil layer I or J and this is switch D
it is a switch if we turn it on it means
U hydraulic redistribution is occurring
that is uh we have to set it at one if
it is zero it means hydraulic
redistribution is not working uh then
switch is off uh will be represented as
zero this will be my workflow U I will
use TCO model where I will drive it
using meterological data and
observational data solve volumetric
water content I will use uh statistical
tool data simulation to constrain uh
parameters to make model output and
observation close to each other uh after
finding optimized parameter I will run
the model and uh get the
prediction so as I said I will create
some modeling scenarios uh since
hydraulic redistribution it is a water
phenomena so I will have some scenario
that will change the
um change the water cont contain in the
soil by changing the precipitation
amount intensity and also it is also
hydraulic redistribution is also a soil
it is also influenced by soil texture so
I will modify I I will manipulate soil
texture and water
table so yeah this is the result yeah
this is the final
slide so uh uh I have some preliminary
result uh where I R the model and I got
some uh cool uh outcomes so here in the
this slide this image it represent the
black dot it is observational data the
blue hydraulic redistribution added TCO
model output and then the Red without
hydraulic redistribution as we can see
with RS root me square error with
hydraulic redistribution model is
performing better and this reason it is
a drier reason um we had very less uh
precipitation during this time from
February to May and and this uh with
hydraulic redistribution it says uh
during dryer reason we have more
hydraulic
redistribution and the right side it
shows the carbon Dynamics so if we have
more improved uh moisture representation
in in the model it means we have more
water available for the photosynthesis
and uh this graph during that same dry
reason uh dry period we can see uh the
blue one is with hydraulic
redistribution we can see higher gpp
value during dry time and uh High U yeah
lower NE means more carbon is being
sequestered uh because of more water
availability in the soil more
photosynthesis has been done by the
plant so summary uh incorporation of
hydraulic redistribution to the too
model improved so water simulation and
hydraulic redistribution is increased
model gpp and and ecosystem respiration
during dry period
then uh the final slide uh data driven
model development and parameterization
uh could enhance the accuracy of model
predictions and incorporation of
hydraulic redistribution may be critical
in simulating carbon cycle and uh yeah
in Dryland
ecosystem
yeah thank you very
much okay starting from the increment of
global warming levels the global surface
temperature has been increasing from the
last century and the past DEC the
temperature of the past decade was
around 1.1 degree warmer than the
pre-industrial level so it is extremely
likely that this temperature increasing
we overpass 1.5 degree at around the
middle of this Century so in order to
mitigate this increasing TR the Paris
climate agreement set a goal to limit
the warming to less than two degree by
the end of this Century so to achieve
these climate goals there are several
climate Solutions focuses on reducing
the greenhouse gas emissions for example
like the energy based solution such use
the renewable or biomass energy to
substitute the traditional fossil fuel
consumption or the finance-based uh
solutions to let the carbon price to
regulate the supply and the demand of
the carbon Market but today I will focus
on another set of climate Solutions the
nature-based climate solution NBCS which
represent the strategies to increase
land carbon storage and avoid greenhouse
gas emissions through natural ecosystem
management and after reading the reports
and the literature I summarize the NBCS
into these following three principles
first it must be coste effective
solutions that uh totally supported by
nature in comp in in contrast to those
Solutions that in the last slides that
by supported by our artificial systems
and second mbcs is about protecting
managing and restoring our natural
ecosystem example of mbcs includes like
reforestation the art forestation Eos e
ecological restoration and agricultural
land management and finally the most
important the NBCS provide Co benefits
for the human well-being and see at the
same time it would have benefits for
natural ecosystem and the NBCS can be
designed to improve the soil health and
bio biodiversity and J resilience in our
natural
ecosystems so how does mbcx work the
answer is to pach and look closer the
grow the forenses of terrestrial plants
also called gpp gross primary production
which is a process that absorbs carbon
dioxide and a major greenhouse gas in
our atmosphere and at the same time it
would release the oxygen here I also
want to mention that can canopy can also
respirate to absorb the oxygen and
release the carbon
dioxide actually uh again also the green
Global carbon cycle figure actually from
the last uh the the last decade the
terrestrial biosphere is the largest
carbon sync in our world and this is the
carbon land carbon sync estimates from
different models the black curves
represent the median of different model
simulations so we can see over the
decades this carbon Sync has
significantly expanded from around 1.2
in 1960s to around 3.5 in 2021 billion
tons carbon flux per year and here I
also want to emphasize the large
divergency from different model output
as show the gray shaded area here okay
so uh how about the MBC the climate
mitigation potential of different mbcs
Pathways and this this figure shows
among all this uh NBCS Pathways here are
the pathways that related to The Car
Land carbon plant sequest plant carbon
sequestration and they all play a
leading role in the mbcs right and here
I also want to uh mention the large
uncertainties in the assessment of this
mitigation potentials as show the long
error bars here right so where does
these uncertainties comes from we know
that mitigation potential equals the
potential extent times the intensity of
flux and which these two terms are
usually from the literature review and
let me take a refra as an example here
the flux tensity should intensity should
be the net carbon sync right so this
figure shows the dominant driver of the
net carbon sync uh globally and and the
positive with areas with the Positive
signal of the clamage and atmospheric
CO2 means the enhancement of the land
carbon sync in a long term long term so
if we just neglect these factors it
would be likely that this a carbon sink
would be over underestimated right and
on the other side if we just do not
consider the impact of disturbance like
the fires in ecosystem or like the
extreme climate events the J or heat uh
it is likely we would overestimate this
intensity flux and also the uncertainty
comes from the potential exchange here
this figure shows the model accumul
accumulation rate carbon accumulation
rate and this study used the uh data
from the literature survey and the
inventory data such as this if it is
from the field measurements of biomass
it is not scalable from the regional to
Global or from Regional to finer
resolution and also moreover there are
uh some uncertainties in the lower low
tempor resolutions those inventory data
usually static or at most once a year
for the frequency so it has low temporal
resolution and uh the existing biometric
data are relatively sparse in spatial
and unrepresentative of our naturally
occurring ingredients in the soil and
the climate conditions and so in my
study I will focus on narrow uncertainty
in the flux density in contrast to the S
studies that's focusing on the carbon uh
storage the biomass I would use the gpp
the grow grow primary production the
carbon flux to quantify those climate
Mitigation Of NBCS of different Pathways
so a prior question to my study is what
are the spatial and temporal dynamics of
gpp
currently there are many existing gpp
quantification appro uh which contains
lot of uh knowledge gaps in my viewpoint
so first uh for the process based models
those are dominated by a dark reaction
Centric model such as the classical
farar photosynthesis model that proposed
in the last century and let's see in the
dark direction of the photos synthes The
Carving cycle was is driven by the
energy in the molecule ADP and ADP H
transformed from the light Direction and
it will absorb the carbon dioxide and
water and output carbon hydrate part of
it would be exported as a gpp and
another part would be used as a
photorespiration so there are lots of
process and parameters needed in this
carbon in this dark reaction Centric
model uh let's see here is the some Pro
there are huge process complexity and
parameter uncertainty in the in this
process based model here the different
colors of the triangles denote all the
parameters needed to simulate the
photosynthesis uh and these parameters
are highly dynamic in space and uh time
in space and time and most of the
parameters are related or varied by
temperature so it is very challenging to
obtain them at the global level uh
moreover let's see here the grow photos
synthesis is calculated by the minimum
of three different limitation conditions
uh so see here is another drawback of
the or complexity in this carbon Centric
model So based on due to the uh process
complexity and the parameter
uncertainties we see large divery in
model simulations here in the yellow box
is all the simulations from the earth
System model we see that although almost
all the models have successfully
simulated the highest two highest carbon
St carbon snc in our world the South
Africa rainforest Amazon rainforest or
the Congo the tropical Africa rainforest
but in terms of the magnitude or the
spatial distribution of the this carbon
sink still have lots of divergency and
also from the satellite observation
based models we see or still find some
diff many differences uh in in their mod
in their estimates
so next I will talk about the data jav
model that's dominantly used in
Satellite and flux power based
observations uh there are major two
approach in on current studies the one
is the light use efficiency Lue approach
the other is the machine learning based
approach in the data in those data dver
model the the input data are usually
from the flx Tower meterological data or
gpp data but actually GP we know that
photosynthesis cannot be measured Beyond
a leaf SC scale so what the gpp is come
from from the the net ecosystem exchange
that measured at the flux Tower and also
this model will select the satellite
based variables as a global feature and
train and validate using different
machine learning methods and the Lue
method and finally it would output and
predict the global gpp
product although it is very powerful for
this data job model I see some drawbacks
in them first as I mentioned before the
gppp measure is not the true GBP from
Tower observations look at the here this
equation the canopy can the what the
flux Tower measure actually is the ne
the net value of photosynthesis and
respiration at daytime which here the
respiration contains respiration from
the leaf from the sterm the soil also
from The Roots right so so the N is
further partition or separate into these
two terms by by algorithm so there are
potential errors in this contents in
this process right okay so also look at
the maps of the flx tower we see that
the flx tower sites are very dense in
some area like the US the Europe or
Eastern Asia however relatively sparse
in some important area like the tropical
Africa so it's the representative of the
flex Tower is especially not exoptable
when the data is upscaled from the size
level to the global
level okay so here is the summary of the
knowledge gaps of existing gpp
quantification approach and in order to
improve the accuracy of gpp estimates
towards informing mbcs I I would I would
propose a more accurate and coste
effective and also scalable uh approach
such as the solar induced foressence C
uh to estimate the gpp flux so the first
question in my study is about about the
dynamic relationship between C and the
gpp C has emerged as a mechanistic proxy
that remote can remotely sense the
vegetation photos censis from space and
here look at the light reaction of the
photosynthesis when the light photons
was absorbed by the Silicon oid
membranes in the chloroplast the lower
stage energy would be excited and
transit to higher state energy however
this higher stage energy is ex unstable
and will quickly Decay into several
Pathways one pathway here is the dis
energy would be dissipated as a heat mpq
and the some part of energy will be used
as in photochemistry via the electron
electron transport and transform the
energy into the molecule ATP and adph
and the very tiny part of the energy
will be reemitted as a fluoresence here
and uh see and and also observed by the
different C sensors in space or uh or
Flex Tower so we can see that c is
really from the side of light reaction
and has mechanistic connection to gpp
Via the electron transport okay so this
is my overall research diagram with
three distinctive objectives and which I
will talk about them in details in the
following slid first question for the
Dynamics relationship between C and gpp
initial findings have pointed the linear
relationship between C and gpp Beyond
The Daily temporal scale and at larger
spatial scales while un linearity
happens at the instantaneous and at the
leavs level also this larity will happen
under some stress conditions so uh but
however we see from the Lu approach the
gpp is directly linked to the radiation
by this simple linear equation uh yes so
but although the Lue plays a major role
in modeling Global gpp a vast number of
complexities uh and process behind this
simple concept of a Lue and here take
example of the electron transport in the
light reaction we we know that there are
two photosystems in the light Direction
the PS2 and PS1 they both absorbs the
photos system and the electron is soured
from the oxidation of water and the
transport from PS2 to PS1 and finally
would be used in uh to reduce the nadp
to regen to generate the nadp edge right
so this process do not reveal in this uh
empirical method so what I would use to
is to develop a magistic model as that
basic to be specifically I will use two
uh models at the leaf level and the
canopy level the canopy level model is
called magistic light reaction model
proposed by our Labs cooperator Dr Le
hungu and the canopy level model is an
analytical solution that accounts for
light Le to canopy scaling Pro proposed
by my by my Prof advisor Dr hon uh due
to the time limitation I will not go
over the detail of these two equations
but we overall we can see that these two
um models have more complicated than the
Lue simple Lue method and really has the
mechanistic directly mechanistic linkage
between the CFE and gpp right so my test
my task is to validate the mechanistic
safe models um yeah so in my study I
will utilize the radiative transform
model as a framework to conduct several
um safe modeling simulations at several
neon Forest sites neon is the national
ecological Observatory Network which
operates 47 territorial sites across 20
eological and climatological domains so
once the C gpp mechanistic relationship
was validated uh is validated I can D I
can use it to dve the spatial Dynamic uh
temporal dynamics of gpp flux right uh
here this figure shows the
characteristic of past current and
future uh emissions with safe observing
capability the increase the substantial
increase number of the space Bond sa
offers me a opportunity to utilize the
satellite SE to derive the global height
resolution and long-term gpp data sites
and another task under this objective is
to utilize the gpp data site I derived
as a benchmark to to analyze the
historical pattern of the historical
simulation pattern of the process based
models and then we can see which model
has the best gpp uh estimates
right okay so finally for the last
question let's come back to the NBCS
hotspots and again this figure shows the
regional level uh climet mitigation
potential of different P NBCS Pathways
and here uh this I in my study I want to
look at the more details for example
from the regional level to the more
final resolution that's the global
Hotpot of NBCS so the first task under
this objective is to identify or map the
global mbcs like the which I mentioned
before like the for reforestation the
forest management of chees in grow plant
and then I will combine with other uh
dat land use cover land use change or
land cover dat set still take the forest
re Forest reforestation as a example uh
I will first identify the areas with
Forest loss and again or areas transform
from no nonforest to Forest and combine
with the gpp combine with the
information from the gpp Dynamics I
direct in the second objective then I
can calculate the climate mitigation
potential of different NBCS pathways
okay so currently I have completed the
first task of my uh all the task that is
to validate the magestic C gpp model in
terms of the model structure the
parameter uncertainties and the
landscape heterogenity and in the future
I will further explore the following
four tasks under the scheduled
timelines and in the last uh summary I
will show again as the research diagram
of my study basically I will identify
the NBCS hotpots and quantifies their
mitigation potential based on the C gpp
mechanistic model I developed in the
first objective and the uh gpp data set
I generate under the in the second
objectives and At Last I will
acknowledge my Committee Member my lab
member my all my Coors and most
importantly is sex for your lessoning
I'm happy to take any
questions
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu